ooh we're coming in hot i have no idea
mr beast will have something prepared
and here we go we're off yeah
charlie has black in the first game it's
gonna be a dutch
now we talked about the move g4 mr beast
likes to
do weird stuff here i mean he this is
already gonna stump him this is for you
jimmy mr beast has faced the dutch
twice and my guess is that he's going to
play the same way that he does against
d5 but it's a really good sign that he's
taking his time here
charlie the dutch we worked on it as
well god i'm going to feel like such a
[ __ ] idiot if there's
oh he's free moving
wait why is he moving i'm pre-moving
baby you shouldn't pre-move
he's pre-moving the first five no no no
don't do that what is he doing
mm-hmm have you noticed oh my god that
is
that is that is next level i mean mr
beast could go e4 here
i hold the future he's a beast but i
don't know about that one
i don't know about that when he's
scaring him i guess it's a gamble i can
look i've i've i've uh instructed him to
be confident i can't criticize him
out of his playbook i think but he can't
he can't pre-move six moves that's
that's too much that's way too much mr
beast could do something trolly
i've still got or by accident and attack
his queen and you could lose a game like
that there's no need to do that
i feel like i've got a good read on this
there's absolutely
no need to but he i mean mr beast has
already spent a minute he's played very
passively in the opening i like what
charlie i mean obviously charlie's
making the moves that he's played a
million times
d6 castles and knight c6 rookie 85 is
like very standard here
i'm not going to mr beast is taking a
big think here i like it
[ __ ] okay don't pre-move charlie don't
pre-move the next move mr beast could go
knight e6 here
why is he pre-moving okay thank god
e6 is good i would have played d5 but
now mr b says d5 which would be
but i don't think he's going to play
that i should have just moved my thank
god whoops
all right okay good position for
charlie's got to get this knight out of
there
mr beast i'm a little bit concerned
about this move that would uh basically
open up the diagonal toward charlie's
king now i don't
know if he's gonna play it mag no thank
you
all right mr b's taking it a long time
here
two minutes after six moves that's what
we like to see
he probably pre-moves yeah but the track
snaps you out
okay he's got 10 26 here this is as good
as it gets he should have gone d5 though
i mean you should
we i need he he should play with tempo
but e6 is e6 is more than acceptable i'm
very concerned for this move like if
beast plays this
it's all right charlie might take it and
that's like you know there's there's
some stuff that happen
like this and you don't want i mean
that's not gonna happen but
i'm gonna try and cook up some but um
beast is way too slow okay h4
so hey i would go h6 just get the hell
get this knight out of there or or maybe
d5 to chase division but wait thank you
you can't warrior packing it now i like
the charlie's thinking yeah this is a
scary line mr beast is
simplified he's playing a scary line but
he's taken a lot of time which i which i
really like
t9k ck thing about prime
i mean beast wants to go h5 this is not
bad actually he's blowing very
aggressively
ikai worry think of the tier one i mean
d5 is good
i would be happy with h6 i would even be
happy with h5 i wouldn't mind h5
i would be happy with d5 i would but
i would be most happy if charlie played
h6 because that would avoid any
checkmate ideas
i don't like that h6 here chase the
knight away d5 is also good
d5 shuts down the bishop i like that
move a lot
and as i've told him 800 times trust
your gut and he's got d5 that's a great
move i'm not a huge fan
that's a great move as long as he
follows it up with h6 that's a great
move
oh and i can't play this now okay
okay so excellent play here by
by um charlie in the early going
okay
so yeah
anyways um mr b's taking another long
think here i like this i like this a lot
he's playing solid chess this is exactly
what we wanted
this is exactly what we wanted um and
the more he
um the more he he he threatens mr b's
pieces the more time
he forces him to take
now beast is contemplating what to do
here but he he is taking a minute on
every move at this rate he's going to
lose on time and move 10.
well knight takes so so so the pawn is
defended guys knight takes e6 the bishop
on c8 defends the pun
and charlie knows this and beast might
be attracted to this now it's very
important
if beast plays a move like h5 here i'd
be a little bit scared about charlie
being winning here
but blundering into some sort of a
checkmate i don't think this is going to
happen though i think beast is going to
move his bishop somewhere
i don't understand why he's taking this
long but this is just
if he continues to take this much time
he's going to lose on time very quickly
and this is exactly how we set this up i
told charlie that he needs to just play
solid chess mr beast will take this much
time
and um he he's just not used to playing
fast
and he's continuing to think he's about
to use half of his time on move seven
now i like mr beast he's he's a great
dude i'm not
by the way like this stream we're
obviously rooting for charlie but
we're not doing it we're trying not to
do it in an obnoxious like in your face
way
and i feel for mr beast he's just not
used to playing fast here so
i'm happy for charlie in the sense that
i think this is good for him but i'm not
trying to make fun of mr beast in any
way
i i hope that makes sense okay so he
moved his bishop
to a square where he he probably should
have gone in like a second but charlie
allowing h5 see that's what concerns me
he didn't ask himself what the threat
was
h5 is super scary here but beast has
spent over half his clock now officially
knight c6 was played too quickly
charlie's got to go h6
i mean h5 h6 would be good for black
because like this is not scary there's
no mates along these lines
i mean scary but there's nothing that
white can do
i'm concerned about h5
[Music]
i don't really have a good plan right
now and he plays it i mean that's
clearly what he studied
yeah that's a concerning thing don't
play knight takes it i mean you can play
okay but don't take
don't take the bishop now take the
knight on g5
do not take that that night he's going
to get chuck baited i mean he's got to
see that
charlie has to take this night after
beast takes the
takes the night we'll see
daniel showed me something like this and
i forgot i'm not bannering to anything
i'm just explaining my rationale here
i think it's actually a rook sack he's
not playing too fast he's playing fine
but
as long as he plays queen takes g5 he
has to see that this knight is hanging
if he gets into this position he's gonna
get checkmated i mean although this is
still good for black
amazing thing is white has nothing but
i'm just very worried that charlie's
just gonna allow a checkmate
oh god okay please take the night
charlie see it take the knight think and
take the knight
don't take that damn bishop do not allow
this
i didn't teach yes yes yes
yes beautiful good boy good boy
that's what we're talking about
all right that keeps the hval closed
he's up a pawn three minutes for beast
and he is in great shape here the only
thing is
watch the discovery
yes he took the right amount of time
look at that 9 30. i like that speed
confidence is good i mean he's played
too fast i'm going to kick his butt for
that
those free moves will never happen again
i feel like that wasn't the right one or
he's gonna be
i mean but this is good this is looking
great
let's have moisture right here okay
so if he makes the discovery charlie
shouldn't just grab the bishop because
that would drop the queen
that would drop the queen i mean he'll
see that obviously he doesn't
he doesn't think of it that way another
10 bucks from fire grounds
mr beast is such a good guy i would
definitely consider i would definitely
do it i mean i'd be happy to
but now below three minutes is mr beast
and he continues to dip on the clock
here
in the line daniel showed me there was
never a knight there
well queen g2 is not the only uh okay
he's done it
okay now charlie just has to no but if
he takes the pawn he gets his queen
trapped oh god
he gets his queen trapped here he gets
his queen trap so charlie just got to
move
just move your queen back i would move
the queen okay he takes it
mr beast is going to see this and this
wins the queen actually but
i mean the good thing is um first of all
this is hard to see
black is probably equal here i mean he's
got rook and three pawns but charlie
might freak out
i mean he also might just flag him what
i'm hoping for is that he just gets
flagged here because he's now almost
below two minutes
oh i just noticed my but um this is a
big mistake by charlie
that puts mr beast into another big
thing though [ __ ] i hope he doesn't see
it
there's increment but beast is way too
slow 11 minutes in he's got two minutes
he noticed that god i just saw it okay
now we talked about the scenario with
charlie
we talked about the scenario with
charlie where if he gets something like
this
then we've talked about what he should
do he should give up the piece for the
most amount of material don't freak out
and resign
give up your peace for everything you
can and here obviously
the biggest thing that you can capture
if you're already dead is the rook
he has to stay calm beast is well below
two minutes he there's no way he's going
to make good moves
here if charlie just stays calm takes
the rook dammit he sees this
oh my god unbelievable play by mr beast
yeah he's crazy to see that
take the bishop take the take the take
the rook rather come on charlie take the
rook take the pawn you're good
damn unbelief but i'm just too fast too
impulsive doesn't consider the
consequences
here i think all right
let's get the most out of it yeah he
can't convert this but only if charlie
takes the right i think is my only
option
that's a crazy move for yeah that's
that's crazy
take the rook charlie come on take the
rookies fine
take the rook on take the damn rook yes
good good good good good very good
very very good this is fine for him he's
he's down a queen for a rook and a
million pawns this is totally good
take the pawn come on charlie take the
pawn yes
yes but b starting to play a little
faster now if beast finds bishop e3 to
defend the pawn
on d4 or if he plays d5 i'll be very
impressed
now look at these pawns by charlie and
this is really nice minute and a half
now by beast
and he continues to play very slowly
bishop e3 should have been played in a
second by mr beast
he's fine i mean position like
objectively
so you guys know is is winning for white
but not completely winning for white
oh my god jesus
every movie funds rook d8 would be a
good move here by charlie to attack the
pawn
yeah beast is clearly very underrated
rook d8 rook tia come on rook d8 bring
the rook and attack the pawn you're good
that hangs this all right
just don't freak out f4 is a good move
too
just flag him here at this point you
just push this flag him
i think yeah this is not this should not
have been allowed i mean this should not
have happened but it's fine
yeah his play is nutty
all right just play rook t8 charlie come
on see the move bishop i mean i would
even be fine with him developing a piece
rook d8 damn girl and he is uh
coming up with some now the key is to
put white under
pressure create threats on every move
take 10 seconds off beast clock every
move
10 20 seconds boom boom boom beast will
eventually blunder there's no way that
he can find continually find good movies
now under a minute
there we go keep the clock ticking
quinty took him
charlie now beast
preparing to castle i mean this guy just
knows what he's doing
over here
well what russian teachers do you mean
russian teacher
but all the uh on behalf of all the
russian teachers
no e5 is great too
eventually be still blunder take the
pawn charlie come on
well charlie has one russian teacher
okay
yeah yeah of course he is but he's
mostly you know
he's he's not charlie's teacher i
thought you meant in terms of like
charlie specifically
of course no of course he does
come on knight d4 stop
uh yeah definitely i have plenty of time
to think it through
he's thinking too much i don't know what
he's thinking about take the damn pawn
he's way over thinking about it
he's just take the pawn e5 whatever just
do something
he's starting as usual like taking five
minutes per move
i think i just want to take now he needs
to take the i mean he needs to move
i i this if this gets into a time
scramble he will lose
if i take with knight he comes yes at
least he can't learn on the queens
anymore
no that's wrong he's about to take he's
got time but it's fine
i'm going to yell at him already he
should take with a knight yes
but he should just make a damn move i
don't know
well he's doubts everything i mean at
some point he just got us to say
f it and make some moves because bishop
takes well you don't want to give away
this bishop this is a really good bishop
you want to keep this bishop take the
pawn come on
bishop h6 he has a disc i mean of course
he probably doesn't see the discovery
against the queen
oh my god this is i'm going to kill him
if he doesn't make him in the next 30
seconds i cannot [ __ ] decide
at all i i mean i just it doesn't matter
how many times i tell him he just
doesn't do it
at some point he starts doubting himself
and he gets into this rabbit hole
and uh and it just doesn't matter how
many times i tell him not to do that
it's unbelievable
all right take the pun he's he's half
he's half of his time down
okay he's panicking yeah and that's it
he just he he doesn't move
it's three minutes three minutes on one
move unacceptable completely
unacceptable
nausea's name of the prime i mean he's
he's for somebody used to this many
people watching him this is not
acceptable make a move damn it
all right i can just send some mixing
limestone thanks for the prime
no this is this is every second that
passes the beating that he's gonna take
from me increases
i i mean i can't believe this he's
seeing his time take down he knows how
time works thank you hybrid
finally yes e5 is a great move now you
should have played it five minutes ago
yes okay good now
now if beast plays d5 i will be
even more impressed but beast is taking
his time
as well he's got 45 seconds now it's a
10 plus 5 time control
and beast bishop h6 expected okay take
the pawn
wow ship h6 is a great move
all right take the pun yeah rook d4 is
fine
pawn d4 is fine take the pawn
that beast all of a sudden starts to
play super fast and super accurately
it doesn't look good to me either my
heart is like beating out of my chest
i mean this is just unbelievable he's
got to make a move come on rook takes
just anything
god damn it
i'm gonna be i mean there's nothing i
did everything i could i mean i
i can only tell him this so many times
there is a point at which
i can't play for him he has to make a
decision
to overcome the psychological problems
and that decision has to come from him
and if you don't make that decision if
you refuse
to make that decision you will always
fall into the same traps
and he's refused to make that decision
and i will have a talk to him about it
okay he's taking the bishop that's fine
and that's fine now knight b5 here is
very strong now his pawns are super
solid
but he's got to make the decision at
some point to just overcome that
psychological problem
i mean oh my god the beast is playing
perfectly actually
and he's playing perfect chess okay
okay so this is this is i didn't expect
this
honestly it won't work
yeah this is crazy
yeah he's he's done some serious
training
okay so i would move the bishops i would
probably i mean rook d7 here
all right relax everybody he's obviously
not cheating mr beast is not cheating
he's just done a lot of training
rook d7 come on bishop e6
blunders the pawn to a fork
he's got to just defend the pawn but
this is looking bad it's down to two
minutes
the way he's playing uh he's gonna lose
on time
he sees rook d7 to play it
it is a best of two i cannot [ __ ]
decide
i mean he's got to just move it's just
unbelievable
i think this is the this is the only
hanging piece it's pathetic to accuse
someone
like mr beast of cheating so i have to
move just
there we go good good boy good boy now
mr beast
his best movie either queen of queen f4
there's no way he plays you
if he castles that's that's okay
now asics get rid of this knight
okay no but he blunders the pawn but
charlie's playing normally and he's
playing decently well
he's gotta chase the knight away and
that's a that's a reasonable move that
takes away
a lot of time off of mr b's clock he's
down at 25 seconds he's using this right
now
abuse is sped up he's he is fed up
move come on mr beast come on come on
charlie
oh king b1 so calm just play
play on the clock come on c5 there we go
d3 push it baby
come on push push it every fight every
time beast thinks more than five seconds
them on
dc yes yes that's exactly how you get it
done
mate
there we go gotcha pre-move close call
oh my god okay that was crazy
you got it oh
rough not a clean okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna write him a couple messages
thanks luisa daisy sunny
the prime cherry resub og g2 nauseous
drum limestone
jacob burns spaghetti zupini
and pie in the two gift subs yes in the
prime
all right platinum i said don't premove
anything in game two
in all caps casey
and there we go they're off e4 now we're
expecting a scandi by mr beast but i
told charlie to be prepared for anything
thank you admiral jones 42 okay e4 so
they're going to go into a vienna
so mr beast deviating for the first time
in his life from the scandi
thank you scores for the tier one but
clearly not prepared for knight c3
clearly not prepared for knight c3 he's
already taking his time thank you
boomers this is for the tier one i gotta
disable the alerts guys
this is crazy
okay f5 is crazy absolutely
i've never i've seen that before i mean
i guess it's a movie just take it i have
looked at so many that is
that is never seen this just take the
mr beast is trying to play the vienna on
charlie and that is not
going to work i think now charlie can
also go knight f3 or ef anything
it's the latvian gambit against knight
c3 but it's just not
good thank you yes i hate my life for
the tier one
good thing he takes his time
should i try and get really good we want
them both to be confused this is the
real test
matalito thank you for the prime yeah
but it's i like that he's taking his
time here i like that he's taking his
time just don't
yeah good good good good don't trust him
don't trust him yet now charlie is the
one threatening queen h5 check beast has
to get his night out which is not an
easy thing to realize
i mean open h5 is almost winning here
queen h5 is almost winning here now he's
got to borrow the knowledge from the
vienna where his opponent has this
and do that against his opponent does he
see it
will he see the check maybe taking it's
it's very bad for your black hair it's
almost lost he's got to see the check i
mean he just has to see it
it's not hard to see because well it is
hard to see but he's got to borrow the
knowledge
he hasn't seen it yet come on no he's
not gonna see it
it's it but in the vienna he always
yeah i mean this is fine this is okay
it's a b-plus kind of move he's still
better
but this is how you know
okay d4 is a great move d4 is a great
move
d4 is a great move though i mean that's
a that's that's a solid move he's still
much better here
now queen h5 would not be winning black
goes kick king up and it's it's a game
but
uh if anything this is a this is a very
good move
this is opening up the center i like it
so
i don't really know how to exploit this
position i would have liked it and he's
in good shape here side of the board
with like a queen
he's in very good shape now beast is
playing a little faster this time in the
opening
okay knight c6 take the pawn that's
another weird move now queen h5 is still
good
maybe i should have done that yeah he's
going to get a
a a serious talking to by me check check
check give the check
give it no check him still good okay
he's taken first that's fine
beast is gonna take even then check is
good scared of g6 but he takes it
he takes the pun
okay but he can't psych himself out like
that
he's got me way out of my comfort zone
here yeah i guess i scared him but it's
fine it's still good
okay d4 i mean the fact that mr beast
plays that moves big queen h5 is
crushing here but he's gonna go in 94.
it's not aggro it's good i mean blocks
my bishop
all right it's winning after win h5 okay
go knight e4
but it wins upon
well he won the first game so
knight e4 is good mr beast has not just
been improving
this is like professional play these
moves are wacky
queenie two no night night move the
knight not knight b5 knight e4 moving
into the center
yeah he's playing too long queen h5 g6
fg6 and then if you take the knight this
wins because it attacks the rope and
checks the king
he's taking too long here again
he wants to go 92 that's so passive
though it's fine it's just passive
bird person thank you for the prime i'm
just gonna all right that's fine my
instinct tells me
i'm not happy with the way he's playing
here right it's it's not terrible
it's not terrible i mean he's still just
better probably he's got anything
flustered i'll tell you
but he's making too many generalizations
he's not trying to calculate variation
he's he's trying to make conclusions
on the basis of how a move looks i've
played like a thousand three-minute
games over the last three months and
i've done
vienna and almost all of them i've never
seen yeah so he's playing much faster
this game he's adjusted somehow
this is a very very reasonable move
charlie is still much better sometimes
it's actually much much better because
he's going to go knight f3 and win this
font
yeah this 92 is a better move than
people realize it is
knight f92 is a much better move than
people realize it is it's actually not
bad
it might actually be top three
it got him frustrated but he's got to be
ready for that beast playing so well
just taking the right pawns and
everything knight f3
f3 the reason 92 is actually not bad is
because
take d4 see this take knight d4 come on
see that you can take the pawn and
defend this one
knight takes d4
he has to see knight takes d4
take the pawn and either knight actually
i i mean i can't see him missing this i
think he sees it
he's looking at it i mean come on just
play it he's gonna play it i mean
there's no other move there's literally
no other move
and it's okay that he's taking a little
bit of time c5 the bishop hangs
take the pawn there he goes that's my
boy
that is my boy he also attacks that is
my boy
there we go that's the best night to
take with cause it opens up the bishop
the reason that's a good night to take
it with us because now you can develop
the bishop
i told him before the game to chase away
beast's active pieces
that's obviously yeah okay so
beast bishop is hanging he's up two
pawns
great great position for charlie here i
can win i should have uh
i should have played this night okay boy
obviously i just noticed
is it too late it's too late i i i did
not mean to appropriate him for myself
damn it i went too strict into the
fundamentals
centralizing knights if i had just
captured oh no this was still blocking
never mind i'm good no regret it's
yeah pre-med too hard thing for the
prime and beast now sinking into the
tank
they're gonna go equal on the clock you
still see a way of winning this bishop
should it stay
yeah this is close well he's we're gonna
have to do some serious remodeling
before his match against ludwig
yeah so charlie wants to go here just to
get get now one of the key principles is
to get rid of your opponent's most
active pieces
and um he
you know that helps that creates um less
of a chance that you're gonna blunder so
this knight on b4 is really strong it's
attacking the pawn it's not actually
that good but it's still a good idea to
get rid of it
still in a tough spot though
okay i don't think if he plays against
like this against he's not playing that
badly give him a little credit yeah yeah
yeah we gotta duck some psychology
ludwig actually blunders a ton yeah
charlie for ludwig is gonna have to be
attentive to the blunders
yeah now beast is uh a minute down on
the clock once he drops
this is looking good because now he's
got a little cushion
do i do that with a bishop bishop g4
would be the best move here
that with a pawn so just to clarify the
reason this is not good is because the
knight
defends the pawn on c2 so white's knight
defends
c2 and attacks the bishop on f5 both
things are that knight is a hero
and it's it's defended by the other
bishop c3 is not legal
what beast should do here is go bishop
g4 in order to pin the knight that
creates a little bit of tension it
doesn't do anything serious you can go
c3
you can go a3 and attack the knight you
could go bishop e2 here and
unpin yourself that's kind of what i
taught him um
so but but now b's taking like five
minutes on this move
no no so so knight f5 is a threat you
don't mind the queen trade queen trade
is good for white because white's going
to be up a piece and the king actually
defends
the pawn on c2 is this whole thing
exhausting free well i'm putting all of
my energy into it mental physical
emotional so
yes but it's also i wouldn't have it any
other way
all right
so let's see beast continuing to think
the longer he thinks the bigger the
cushion
the bigger the cushion
mr b's best move like i said is to move
the bishop away i mean his bishop is
saying thank you grins for the prime
appreciate the two months
thank you everybody for all the support
throughout this very stressful but very
fun time
all right so let's see what he ends up
doing
and this move92 was actually a very good
move because
this represents charlie used to be in a
situation where
all he would do is go forward
the fact that he's willing to make a
retreating move is important to me now
taking the bishop is
that was an amazing move by mr beast
because he defends the bishop thank you
and then the queen will replace the
bishop so charlie's got to go a3 here a3
would be the clinical russian move
a3 will be the russian move here come on
a3 is the russian school of chess
get rid of good night move get rid of
the good knight come on
he moved i have no way of exploiting um
no he did not move c3 is good too both
moves are good i told him to chase away
his best pieces
i would like to somehow pin this queen
to the key yeah this is fine i mean you
could just go like this and castle
still there that's fine too let's see
bishop e2 and castles is good
it should be five beast is gonna go c6
then you can go back that's also good
you have to drop out bishop b5 is good
because beast might blunder his queen
although i don't think so he's going to
see c6
but yeah yes i mean look we got to give
him a little credit he is playing
some clinical chess right here getting
rid of his opponent's most active pieces
this is the freaking man thank you
robert
well it has no but his hard work has
been paying off
or maybe he wanted to protect the bishop
so this is taking
way too long on simple moves as well i
mean he's got a similar problem
knight c6 and then bishop b5 would be an
amazing move to pin the knight i think
he's gonna do it i believe in him now
i think he's in control of the situation
i get the sense these and control the
situation
he's in control of the situation
300 bits no he knows he's in control of
the situation beast time is dwindling
with every second
he's thinking on his time doing
everything right this is looking good i
just noticed oh my god i [ __ ] up
i [ __ ] up whoops
i just noticed a big flaw
um i mean i don't think so abby
but
yeah he'll play bishop e5 that's that's
a charlie move okay so you blunders a
piece
you saw it e blunders a piece
no no knight c2 come on charlie knight
c2
knight c2 there we go just easy take the
queen
beast is going to castle but he needs to
see the block you need to block the
track don't move the king
do not move the king and blunder the
knight
bishop he's up a piece he's up a piece
so i don't lose bishop d2 i think that's
the only move i have he's up a piece
i'm going to time people out for saying
beast is cheating by the way
it's not acceptable no then i just
pinned my knight to my king he just
takes
there should be two no no no no don't go
okay great i mean look
this guy's he needs to give himself more
credit than he does
there we go he's up a piece in the end
game
and more time on the clock 549 is not a
lot for charlie though
beast is playing so well though it's
crazy
all right knight t4 the problem with
knight d4 is that it would land in the
pin and you would go c5 to win the night
well i need to castle right and we've
talked about how people in this
tournament are underrated
now he's three minutes up on the clock
all right
okay
he almost went at fd4 but then that that
first of all you can take this knight
and take the other knight with a piece
but yeah he sees that kind of stuff
yeah that's a that's a bad movie just
simplifies the position for no reason
yeah that helps charlie out a lot
because now
he can just develop his bishop to c4 and
he knows how to win these positions
thank you amanda
appreciate it
well for someone who's trained three
hours he's playing incredibly
and h5 yeah so he's he's sort of
floundering get the bishop out get the
rook out
push the passer knight g5 is a great
move here if you want to be a little
adventurous but the way we trained he
should develop the rest of his pieces
uh he is playing he's not playing above
his level he's playing above his rating
which is not suspicious at all because
he's underrated
so let's be very clear here
i mean there's this right here if he
gives it to me yeah 50 million subs is
crazy so
okay get your bishop out charlie he's
already thinking too long he can't
deliver any checks right now
nike five is a charlie kind of move but
i also think he's he's gonna
get one of these pieces in too long you
see what black has no threats
zero he's gotta make he's gotta move a
little faster here yeah there's no
checks you can deliver
anything is good that's a great move
knight g5 and get get the knight over
here for a fork
that's a charlie knife right there i
mean because it's going to take this
beast a while
knight h6 here would defend that that
square that's a brilliant move but it's
going to take a while for him to find
okay rook c7 is fine but now bishop c4
is a crusher
bishop c4 knight e6 is good too i mean
e6 is great bishop c4 bishop d3
i can probably no no bishop c4 because
bishop he
and i told him a million times rook and
king on the same diagonal
rook and king on the same diagonal i
appreciate it blood's the man blood is
the man
yeah no i appreciate that a lot it's
this is his e6 is great guys in a good
position there's multiple good moves as
long as he moves thank you
archaeological
thing to bowler come on make a move
it's bishop c4 you got this
g3 is great but a charlie move as
bishops before i told him
to continue developing his pieces when
he's in time pressure luis
he is overthinking this pushing is great
but he has to play faster i mean he's
just he's burning clock for no reason
see what happens yeah good great move
great movie six and then
but then get your pieces out my man
another good move would be rookie one
supporting that pawn from behind
i could have pinned the rook
when he gets into the game he tends to
he tends to forget the general
principles get your rook in come on get
your bishop in bishop b4 is a great move
bishop d3 come on come on come on come
on there we go great another fantastic
move
simplify the position wow i mean this is
this is phenomenal play by charlie
phenomenal play
phenomenal play
okay
okay wow beast is holding up though
do i just take the bishop or do i keep
it no
flying lukey thank you for this year one
okay charlie move
come on come on my man bishop d3 get the
bishop out take on f8 simple chest let's
go
three minutes um
come on try to move come on please move
please move what if i brought my knight
he's just overthinking it knight f7 is
great move here
i'm not texting charlie relax
okay he he needs to move he needs to
move
he's moving way too slowly i mean it's
just it's it's a
i don't know if he's scared of wondering
but um i am texting robert
oh my god come on move
he's way up on time but this is not this
he's going to lose on time like this i
mean he's just going to do it
there we go he can't allow this to get
close now beast is taking
too long on recaptures
knight f7 come on charlie knight f7 slam
that knight in there
intercepting the rook f3 is good knight
f7 bishop d3 he's got it
oops not not bishop e3 bishop d3 decent
i mean he gets he gives this pawn up but
it doesn't matter
he gives this pawn up but it doesn't
matter he blundered and b sees it
instantly
sloppy play by charlie just move the
damn king move it up don't move it down
move it up move it up come on
there we go my man
and then knight f7 beast is gonna take
the pawn
knight f7 and rook d1 see what charlie's
not doing he's too slow involving his
pieces
i don't mind that giving up that pawn i
don't care about that that's also going
to make beasts think a little bit longer
knight f7 come on oh what a move
he wants to meet him oh my god that's a
cruel move right there
oh my lance that's a brilliant move if
i've ever seen him come on
he's got a beast will see it though
won't he he did not just do that
oh and beast blunder's a rook
he panics take the rook charlie take the
rook charlie
do i block or just take the rook i think
i have to block her i just give this
away what is he sitting there
what oh my he's
he's probably gonna win oh my god
charlie what are you doing
what are you doing take the rook damn it
okay it's fine he's completely winning
but
are you freaking e7 just wins on the
spot though i mean that is just
unacceptable but
he played an amazing game that one
mistake that was going to get him a
beating beast is finding all the moves
in time pressure bishop f7 come on
it was made no no why was in check why
wasn't check relax everybody white was
in check
he should have just taken the rope
bishop f7 come on
my god how do you miss that rook what
bishop f7 95 move
b's finding everything in time pressure
good move good move come on beast
finding moves though in time pressure
rookie eight man
how does he find all this in time
pressure just 95 keep laying it on he's
gonna blunder eventually
knight e5 come on 95
taking too long rookie one is a good
move just
solid defensive move b5 amazing move
again
rook c6 wins though that one's another
pawn bishop d3 is a great move
b is going to move his work to g4 though
or g2 is the best move
oh rook gt blunders the brook again take
the rook there we go
ruff
come on charlie just take the pond
finish with this
jesus crisis there we go that's my boy
that's how we do it here in the south
take the rook take everything take the
knight take the rook take everything
take everything
don't stalemate him a stalemate is even
fine he draws fine for him take the rook
take
everything rook out fade is fine and he
resigns and that is the
match now just to show
why we were all so upset this is check
guys you can't give the mate this is
check to the white king
but the rook is hanging congrats to
charlie that was
big win i am very happy ninja um
beast mr beast is a beast absolute beast
he is going to go far huge huge
performance by mr beast
huge performance by mr beast but charlie
is uh he deserves a lot of credit for
that now i'm not going to rip him a new
one or anything i'm going to be critical
when he deserves to be critical phrase
worthy position and you deserve to be
praised for the thank you for the prime
god damn it's not all about giving
someone a beating immediately that's not
that's not what good coaching is the
accuracy of this one
but he needs to get some puzzles all
right